[Music]
death is the enemy
the first enemy and the last
[Music]
the enemy always leaves and we still
need to fight him
okay what he's got on
[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
7 preview video now that we have seen
episode 5 it's time to take a look at
the upcoming episode which is episode 6
since this is a shortened season episode
6 should be the most action-packed
episode because Game of Thrones
typically does this right before their
season finale and I have to admit the
episode 6 preview trailer might be the
best one we have ever seen or at least
the best one I have ever seen it almost
feels like this next episode is going to
be more like a movie than an actual
episode from a television show I am
extremely excited for this one ever
since all the spoilers started being
confirmed
I knew this might be one of my favorite
episodes of all time and there will be
spoilers in his video too so proceed
with caution now let's begin this next
episodes main focus will be on the
mission beyond the wall Jon Snow and
company are on a mission to capture a
white so they can take it back to King's
Landing to try and prove the Circe that
the threat beyond the wall is real they
need to forget about who is going to
rule the Seven Kingdoms and focus on
stopping tonight King and his army from
bringing a storm to Westeros and
completely annihilating everything and
everyone in sight Jon Snow is
accompanied by an awesome team right now
he has torment Jorah
Berek Thoreau's Gendry the Hound in a
few other random wildlings with him as
they go in search of the dead we last
saw them walking out of the tunnel north
of the wall and they were walking right
into a snowstorm that was a complete
whiteout making it extremely hard to see
anything in front of you this seems like
a suicide mission right now but their
Valyrian steel plot armor will get most
of these men back to safety but not all
of them when the preview trailer begins
you can see the group of men traveling
out way beyond the wall across the
frozen landscape they shot these scenes
in Iceland and I have to say this
location is stunning looking you can get
a real sense of how far away they are
from any civilization if you remember
from the last episode when brain sent
the Ravens over the wall they had to fly
a good bit of distance before they
actually solved the army of the Dead so
Jon and his companions have many miles
of hiking to do before they actually get
there in order to find them they will be
following the path that the Hound saw
and his vision in the flames they are
looking for a mountain that is shaped
like an arrowhead after what I'm sure is
days of hiking they
do find the mountain and this is the
same mountain we have seen before this
is the exact same location that children
of the forest actually made the night
king this is a very important landmark
in Westerosi history and this will now
become the battleground for Jon Snow and
his companions before the battle begins
beric Dondarrion does say something
interesting too Jon Snow
Barrack says death is the enemy the
first enemy in the last the enemy always
wins but we still need to fight him
Barrack is exactly right death does
always win all of us will die all men
must die at some point but we must not
go down without a fight Jon Snow
typically knows nothing but this time
you can tell he does know something he
knows something is wrong the army of the
Dead is about to ambush Jon and his team
if you look to the left of Jon right
here you can see an opening between the
mountain this is where John and company
will be funneled through this opening as
they run from the dead out onto the
frozen lake I believe the night king
knew they were coming and he set out
this trap he has John surrounded he just
doesn't know it yet but then all hell is
going to break loose
thousands of whites pour out from
between these mountains leaving Jon and
everyone he is with with no choice but
to run they will run through the gorge
and out onto the frozen lake desperately
trying to escape you know that cold air
they are sucking in as they run is
cutting through their lungs like
Valyrian steel as they run to escape
they will realize they are surrounded
with nowhere to go their only option
will be to fight they will be closed
into a tight circle with everyone's
backs against each others but what do we
say to the god of death not today the
trailer then cuts to Winterfell where
Arya and Sansa are beginning to bump
heads Littlefinger has set a trap that
Arya is beginning to fall into Arya
actually underestimated Littlefinger and
she thought she could spy on him but
Littlefinger is the master at this
Littlefinger has been doing this for
decades he planted a letter that Cersei
4 songs at a write to her brother raw
back when he was going to war insta
Lannisters Songza signed a letter asking
Rob to swear fealty to Joffrey now Arya
is going to believe Sansa would also be
willing to overthrow John as the king
little fingers gain may last for an
episode or two but it's not going to
last forever like I have said before
Arya will kill Littlefinger what his own
dad
back up north the battle begins John and
company are surrounded on all sides but
they aren't going to go down without a
fight
you can see Gendry smashing a white with
this war hammer and you can also see the
hound smashing a white with Gentry's war
hammer as well there has been some
controversy around this scene because
most people think the hound picked up
ginjuries hammer after he died but I do
not believe that is the case I don't
think entry is going to die in this
episode I think Gendry most likely drops
it in the Hound picks it up her Gendry
gives it to the Hound to use while he
runs for help because the leak did say
Gendry would run back to the wall for
help there is even a scene in this
trailer that shows some backup running
out beyond the wall at east watch you
can see it's the same spiked gate at
eastwatch-by-the-sea and they are
running towards the storm this is
probably some extra man going to help
them fight now that they know what's
going on or they are coming out to meet
somebody who made it back from the
fighting we can also see Jon Snow
fighting a white Walker again in this
trailer this makes the second time Jon
had to face one one verse one and you
have to wonder if the White Walkers are
trying to get to Jon specifically almost
as if they know he is special
unless Jon went after the white Walker
himself because he's the one who has the
valerian steel I was hoping we would see
everyone with some dragonglass weapon
since Jon has been mining it for a while
now but the only one I've seen with the
weapon that looks like dragon glass is
tormund
I guess the weapons can only help you so
much when you are extremely outnumbered
there is no way Jon and the rest of his
team are going to be able to make it out
of here alive without the help of
Daenerys and her dragons in the trailer
you can see Tyrion and Daenerys are both
in the war room together and Tyrion
looks very worried they know the chances
of them coming back alive are pretty
slim Daenerys has to be worried about
Jorah and now that she's falling in love
with John I'm sure she's getting very
worried about John also Daenerys will
decide that she needs to go help John
and she will leave dragon stone with all
three of her dragons Tyrion will advise
against this but Daenerys is going to go
anyway she will show up with their
dragons and start burning White's by the
dozens which will clear a path for the
men to escape you can see the big fires
in the back of these photos so it's
pretty clear the dragons did show up and
started providing air support the Hound
will subdue a wight and take it back to
King's Landing for proof Daenerys will
use her dragons sort of like an uber
escort everyone back to the wall safely
John will end up stranded all alone
still surrounded by the whites but
before Daenerys can leave the night king
will kill one of the dragons
I know people still don't believe me
about this but I've 100% believed a
dragon will die during this mission
Daenerys will suffer a great loss this
season once again proving to her that
she needs John's help just as much as he
needs hers it's going to look like John
is going to die while he's surrounded by
the whites all by himself it will look
like he has no way out but his uncle
Benjen will show up and give John his
horse to escape and get back to the wall
you can see John riding off on benjin's
horse in the trailer and it's going to
be tough seeing benjin gets worn by the
whites now I know he was already
partially turned and we've only seen
Benjen in a few episodes but I really
loved this character I would hate to see
him get fully turned to the dark side
but he will sacrifice himself in order
to get John out of there so I have to
respect him for that so rest in peace
uncle Benjen you will be missed but
there is one more scene in this preview
trailer that I want to talk about and
it's the very last scene you can see a
white Walker sitting on a horse but the
night team is actually on foot and he's
walking forward towards something I
believe this is the night king walking
towards the dead dragon the night king
will bring the dragon back to life sort
of he will now have his own dragon to
mount and it's going to be absolutely
terrifying it's going to look incredible
watching a battle of the dragons in the
sky
I just hope John's going to get his own
dragon too so he can take the night King
on himself it would also be really cool
if bran could actually harness his
powers to his full potential and warg
into the night Kings dragon to regain
control of it I think that would be
really interesting but it might not be
likely but comment down below and let me
know if there was anything I missed
during this breakdown I would love to
hear what you have to say as long as
it's respectful thank you to everyone
for taking the time to watch this video
I really do appreciate that and I also
have to thank my patreon supporters I
hope everybody has a good day bye
[Music]
[Music]
you